[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHEAL KELLY:
Wanted to start out--
kick it off by talking a little
bit about the state of database
monitoring today.
We'll spend a couple of minutes
on this talk about Stackdriver
and BindPlane and
then go into a demo
and finally talk with one of
the early customers that are
actually using this solution.
But the reason to talk about
the state of database mattering
is just to get on the same page.
Can I ask how many
people here-- is
it your primary responsibility
to be managing databases inside
of your environment?
And then for how
many people is it
a secondary or tertiary
responsibility for you?
So I would imagine a
lot of you have already
been through this experience,
but in the last five to 10
years, there've been a couple
of pretty significant changes
in the database landscape.
If we go back that period
of time, a lot of companies
were really just focused on
maybe one proprietary database,
and they would use that
in almost every situation
inside of their environment.
And they were run it
on the same thing.
So it'll be-- a lot
of times you would
have a proprietary database that
you're paying licensing fees.
Maybe it was running
on prem on VMware.
And that was
basically everything
that you were dealing with in
it was much simpler than what
we're seeing today
because really what we've
seen over the last few years
is a pretty quick migration
not only to the cloud--
[INAUDIBLE] dealing
with that same database.
It maybe migrated to the cloud,
or it may be in both locations
but then also in the
number of database types
that we're dealing with.
And that's really where we've
seen the biggest explosion.
So it started with
companies moving
to open source
databases, the same types
of relational
databases, but they
didn't want to pay those
same fees that they
were paying in the past.
But they still they
still kept those prior--
the databases they
had previously.
So they still had the
Oracles and the SQL servers,
but they just added
in another layer.
Then really the next step was
to move to NoSQL databases so
a lot of cluster databases.
And then finally we'd moved
to fully hosted in the cloud
databases.
So really what
that says is we've
got this hugely complex
problem that we didn't have
to deal with a few years
ago, and what we've noticed
is the tools really
haven't kept up.
So you don't have an
easy solution out there,
and that's the
problem that we're
trying to solve here with
BindPlane and with Blue Medora
with BindPlane and Stackdriver.
So if I step back
and say let's start
by trying to find a
common set of things
that we're looking for
in all of these databases
because we know we have--
maybe we have half a dozen
to a dozen inside
of our environments
that we need to monitor.
We want to try and find the
common threads between those.
And really what we're looking
for in all situations is--
in roughly in order,
we want to know
the health and availability
of the databases.
We want to understand
the performance--
we need to be able to see the
performance of the database
and understand when there's
a clear degradation.
We want alerts
from the databases,
things like root cause analysis
so the ability to figure out
why this is happening.
And then finally optimization
so the ability to see capacity--
to plan capacity and we
want that across the board.
So that's number one what
we're looking for here.
But it's a really good
idea not to stop there.
What we really want to do
is go one level further
and look at the
infrastructure underneath it.
And this is more
challenging because we
have a situation now
where you have some that
are in the cloud, some that are
on prem, some may be in GCP,
but you may also be using
other public clouds as well.
And that can make these
types of metrics challenging,
but if you really
want to get to a spot
where you're not
pointing fingers
throughout the
organization, it's
important to have all of these.
So this is the challenge
that we're faced with.
If we want to be able
to get all those metrics
and get that visibility at the
database and infrastructure
layer, we have a
lot of data sources
that we're going to--
that we need to deal with.
From the metric side,
we have API metrics
for a lot of your
NoSQL databases.
For Cassandra, you're going
to have to go through an API.
You'll have JDBC for all
the traditional relational
databases, but it's going to
be different for each one.
We have logs for queries and
alerts for both of those.
And then the same thing done
at the infrastructure layer,
we need to get the cloud
metrics, virtualization
metrics, host logs
for both of those.
So getting all of that and
pulling it all together
is one of the big
challenges here.
So let's talk about
the solutions.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
So Mike's just
described a sticky
situation that a lot of us
found ourselves in recently.
What can we use?
What tools are available
to help us mitigate
this to give us a
single pane of glass
set of observability tools?
The first I'm going to
talk about is Stackdriver.
How many of you are familiar
with or use Stackdriver?
So I'm not going to spend
too much time on this,
but I want to remind you
just in case you only
use part of Stackdriver
and you're not
aware of all of
the other features,
Stackdriver is Google Cloud's
monitoring and observability
tool.
We also have application
performance management tools
as well.
Stackdriver has
three basic pillars.
There's monitoring, which
will be our focus today,
there's logging, and there's
APM as I just mentioned.
And for all Google
Cloud Services,
this all happens automagically.
You spin up your GCP
instance of whatever it is,
and you get your metrics
and your logs in Stackdriver
without any additional
instrumentation.
So what we're
really talking about
is adding that level
of observability
for your third-party
applications
that you're running
on Google Cloud
or your third-party
applications that you're
running on prem or in
other clouds as well
as the underlying
services that you're
using on prem in other clouds.
And what solution
are we using to get
those metrics and those
logs into Stackdriver?
We're using Blue
Medora's BindPlane.
BindPlane is essentially an
agent as a service offering
that allows you for
metrics to deploy
a single metric collector
to your environment.
As long as it can talk to all
of your different services
that you're monitoring, it can
pull those metrics together,
send them off to
BindPlane and then
send them along to Stackdriver.
I'm not going to spend
too much time talking
through this picture because
you'll see our demo later,
and that's a little more
interactive and exciting.
But I do want to mention
that BindPlane supports
about 150 different services
ranging from bare metal
hardware all the way up
to third-party application
services.
And it's available
at no additional cost
to Stackdriver users.
So if you're sending your
metrics into Stackdriver,
you'll pay Stackdriver
for your custom metrics,
but you're not going to
pay BindPlane as well.
There's no added fee.
We're talking specifically
about databases here,
and we did want to
list out the databases.
This is a list today.
There are several others
that are in the pipe,
but BindPlane offers about
12 different integrations.
If there is a
database that you care
about that isn't on this list,
come up and talk to us after.
Come find Blue Medora at
their booth or come find me.
We would love to
get your feedback,
and there's a pretty
fast turnaround time
on all of the
instrumentation that's
required to add a new service.
We're also going to talk
about these specific types
of infrastructure so Google
Cloud obviously but also
on premise to have
virtualized and bare metal.
And we'll touch on other cloud
vendors' observability as well.
Again, I'm not going to go
too much into depth with this
because the demo is a
little more interesting,
but BindPlane gives us
a huge amount of control
over those metrics that we're
pulling from a given service.
You may not be
interested in anything,
and BindPlane
gives you KPIs that
are flagged as things that you
probably do want to report on.
But this is just a view of
the level of configurability
where you can select
exactly which metrics
are important to you
and make sure those
are available in Stackdriver.
And then you can see here on
the right what observability
looks like in Stackdriver.
We've got here a slow
query log showing up
in Stackdriver monitoring.
And so this is the solution
that we're talking about today,
centralizing database monitoring
across clouds, across on prem
with Stackdriver and BindPlane.
We are focusing on monitoring.
I do want to mention that
logging support is also
in alpha right now
with BindPlane,
and so if you're interested
in joining that program,
please come talk to us after.
That really allows you to
centralize all of your signals
for your databases in one place.
Demo time.
MICHEAL KELLY: Great.
Thanks, Marie.
So we're going to
go into a demo.
Going to talk about a
few different things.
One, how do you set up
BindPlane and Stackdriver?
We'll do a quick overview
of the Stackdriver
in the database
monitoring solution
and then go through
how you would
solve a couple of problems
using this combination.
And then at the end, I'm going
to take a few minutes just take
a look at our new logs alpha
that we have available.
So what we're looking
at here is BindPlane.
It's a product by Blue Medora.
It's a SaaS application.
And the intent of
it is like we've
mentioned to extend Stackdriver
beyond just Google products
into databases but
also infrastructure,
other clouds, other workloads
that you may be interested in.
And the way it
works is we have--
in this case, I'm monitoring
three different data centers.
So the one data
center on the right
is on prem data center
for monitoring VMware.
We're monitoring a number of
different physical systems
like Pure Storage, some Cisco
networking gear as well as
servers, and then a range
of different database types
as well.
So we're gathering
all that data.
We're sending it
up to BindPlane,
and then it's going
directly to Stackdriver.
We also have a data center
here that is GCP based.
And in this case, you'll notice
we're not monitoring GCP.
That as we mentioned
is already baked in,
so you have availability--
you have the observability
into all the GCP metrics
for the infrastructure.
But we do add
monitoring for things
like databases or
any other workloads
that you could be running there.
And then the last data center is
another public cloud that we're
monitoring where
we can pull data
from those specific services
that you're using there
as well as databases or other
workloads you could be running.
The idea is that
you can use this
even if you are running
on multiple clouds,
even if you have a data center,
or have databases on prem.
We can pull it all together
into a single solution
and then get visibility to all
that inside of Stackdriver.
So let's take a closer look
at the collector first.
So I mentioned that we
have a collector installed
in each data center.
So this doesn't need
to be installed locally
on your databases.
It will connect remotely
to those databases
as long as there's a
network visibility.
And we've made this as simple
as possible to install.
So you just choose the platform
that you want to install it on.
In this case, I'm just going
to choose Mac OS for a demo.
We have in most cases a single
line installer, so we just
copy this, paste
it in my terminal,
and depending on the network
connection speed here,
it's going to download
the collector.
And really this is a very
small, small collector
because it doesn't
have any of the plugin.
So the 150 or so different
extensions that we support
aren't downloaded
all at the same time.
What the collector does is--
it's a simple
Java-based application
that can run any
of these plugins
that I'm going to show you.
Can gather data and
is fully managed
by the BindPlane service.
So it's one of the
great things about this
is you are unlikely
to need to go back
into the server to configure a
JSON file or modify anything.
Here we can handle that all
remotely through BindPlane
itself.
So if I flip back, I see that
the collector that I installed
locally has reached
back out to BindPlane,
and it's registered itself.
Now if I wanted to, I can
convert this to a group.
And this is, if you have
very large environments
or you have availability
requirements,
what we recommend
is building out
a cluster of these collectors.
It's very simple to do,
and it'll automatically
handle failover as well as
increasing the throughput
if you have a very
large environment.
But for now, I'm just going to
leave that single collector.
We'll see that
it's now available
inside a BindPlane
as my new data
center, which is just my laptop.
And we need to add a source.
So you can see these are the
sources that we're currently
monitoring.
To us, a source just
means could be a database.
It could be a VMware
instance, vSphere instance.
It could be a physical server.
And we can see all of the
sources that we have available.
So we have public cloud vendors.
We have physical
compute so things
like Dell servers,
VMware, vCenter instances,
the databases, which we're
going to talk about more
today, things like load
balancers-- popular load
balancers as well as network
switches, physical storage.
So your NetApp or your Nimble
or EMC is all available.
And even some manager of
managers or larger applications
like SAP, IAS, Jboss.
So it's pretty wide ranging
and it's rapidly expanding.
Like Marie said,
we're always looking
for feedback from
customers to hear
what you're looking for next, so
we can add that to our roadmap.
But today I have a
Postgres database
that's running on my laptop,
so I'm going to choose that.
I will choose the new
collector that I just created.
And we'll configure it.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES: And
as Mike is configuring it,
we're going to ask all of you
to not hack his local Postgres
database using the credentials
he's about to type in.
It's extremely secure.
MICHEAL KELLY: Yeah.
And no SSL.
That's how I secure my database.
So we'll test the connection.
And what this is going to do--
so if I had put in the
incorrect credentials--
I'll even show you.
Let's say this is wrong.
If I hit test
connection, this is
going to attempt to log in,
attempt to collect data,
and then identify if
there are any problems.
So we want to have a
good tight feedback
loop to make this configuration
process as easy as possible,
and this is one of the areas
I think can be challenging.
If you're dealing with
a large environment
and you need to get
monitoring setup,
if you don't have
that feedback, it
can take a lot longer
than necessary.
It's really simple.
This is pretty
much what you would
need in the vast
majority of databases
that you want to
monitor, just to host
a port that will provide
the default and credentials.
And we'll let you know if you
click through into our help
settings, we'll show the
minimum user required
for every database type.
So we're not asking you to give
up admin rights to a database
to monitor it.
We will have the
minimum required
user for each of these.
Going to click Add and
this will now show up
inside of my environment.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And, Mike, what
if I had a bunch of
environments that I wanted
to install the collector in?
MICHEAL KELLY: That
is a good question.
So for customers that have large
environments or a lot of these,
we're not going to ask you
to go in through the API
or through the UI
every single time.
We have an API
designed specifically
for that to allow
you to script out
the installation of collectors,
even attach to a chef
script, things like that.
So now you can see, I
have a Postgres database.
It's collecting data.
It's sending all of that
data directly to Stackdriver.
And if I drill in, probably
have all the metrics
shut off right now.
But just to give you an
idea of the type of things
that we gather, these are all
of the available resource types.
So you can see we have obviously
the databases and instances
but also things like the
index, the query, query plans,
and more.
And if I drill into one
of these specifically,
you can see all of the specific
metrics that are available.
Now one of the things we do
because we're really intended--
we're intending to serve
a wide audience here,
and so we don't
expect you necessarily
need all of these metrics.
And we'll let you
know what the KPIs are
and what may make the most
sense by flagging them here.
So if you're setting
this up and you're not
really sure what
you want to look at,
we recommend that you just
enable the KPIs to get started.
And for the folks that if it's
your primary responsibility
to manage databases,
there's a good chance
you know what you
want to look at.
You have ideas of what
those specific metrics are,
and you can go through
pick those out as well.
So that's an overview
of BindPlane,
but now I want to show you
what it looks like we actually
jump into Stackdriver.
So this is Stackdriver.
This is the project that I'm
sending all that data to.
The first thing I
want to show you
is just the access we have now.
So just like with your Google
metrics, click in here.
I just want to filter and
show you that we have--
so if I want to do a search
on Cassandra metrics,
those are all available here.
Let's say I want to
look for some Cisco
hardware, a little bit
of a slow search but--
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES: Turns
out the Wi-Fi in movie theaters
is not always the best.
MICHEAL KELLY: One
more shot here.
There we go.
So now you see all
the Cisco so this
would be your Cisco hardware
servers also network here.
It's all available.
Everything that you saw
there that we're sending over
is now-- now shows up inside
of your metric explore.
And you can use
it for everything
that you're normally using
Stackdriver for so you
can create alerts on it.
We have some that
are available here.
So here's an example of
an alert that we've set up
for a database specifically.
So it's a buffer
cache hit ratio check.
So we have this on all of
our SQL Server databases
to flag when we notice that
there is a buffer cache hit
significantly below well--
below 1 for over a
certain amount of time.
And that's an important one
for us to keep an eye on.
And what we've done is
just in case somebody that
may not be familiar with this
comes in and gets this alert,
we're going to make sure
that it's really clear what
they need to do.
So we've provided
the documentation,
the links to where you can
go to get more details on how
to resolve that.
And what we're
doing today is we've
built up a list of these
incidents that are available.
We can provide them to you
as part of the installation
process if that's helpful.
Or for folks that have a really
good idea of what they want
and what they need to see,
it's easy to build your own
and build your own
alert structure.
So next thing I want to take
a look at was the dashboards.
And this is just
giving you an idea
of what you can do with
Stackdriver and with all
the information
that's available.
So in this case, what I have
is one of those databases
that was running on prem.
It's running on a
Pure Storage array.
It's using VMware.
It's running in vCenter as well.
And I have an issue that
came in from a customer.
So the application that's
using this database,
they've said that
they've noticed
deteriorating conditions.
And so we want to go
in and take a look
at how do we find
that-- how do we
find where that's coming from.
And this is one
of the big things
that we're trying to solve
here is how do we prevent teams
from pointing the finger
at the other group.
So is it a database
issue if you're on prem?
There's a lot of complexity.
Is it actually a
storage issue, or is it
a virtualization issue?
And that's what we're
identifying here.
So if you look what we've
done is pull together
some key metrics from all of
the components in the stack.
So I'm looking at the Pure
Storage host latency, which
is spiky, but nothing is jumping
out at me as a clear issue.
I can go and I see--
well, I'm seeing some repetitive
vCenter host memory used.
So these are spikes
in the host memory
that that SQL Server
database is running on.
I also see disk weight,
and I can drill--
I can identify the specific
database this is running on.
So it's not disk wait
on tempDB or master.
This is specifically on
my app zero database.
So I know there's wait time.
Operations are
increasing as well.
I'm seeing a large spike
in activation count,
and here's the problem.
So I see specifically--
I can narrow it
down to the queries,
and I can get access to
that individual query,
the query text, that seems
to be causing a major spike
at this time every hour.
So what I'm going
to do is go back--
if I'm the
application owner, I'm
going to take a look at
what's running this query.
Either optimize it, or
we'll modify the frequency
that that's running.
But it lets you get
through what could normally
take a lot of
interactions jumping back
and forth between a storage
team, virtualization
team, a database team,
or the Cloud team.
So that's one example
of an on prem use case.
Let's take a look at
something similar in--
if you're running it in GCP.
So really what we're trying
to show here is side by side
how can we use
this data in a way
to help explain what's going on
and make it really obvious when
an issue at the infrastructure
or GCP layer may be occurring--
may be caused by the
database or vice versa.
And so what we have
on the left here,
these are metrics
coming from GCP.
So this is the
performance of the disk
that a database is running on.
And one thing I'll point out
is we see these read spikes.
And so without any
database visibility,
I really don't know what's
causing that read spike.
But since we do have those
metrics for the SQL Server,
I can take a look
at that read spike
that I'm getting from GCP.
I can correlate it back
to the database that's
running on that.
And, again, I can see it's my
app GCP database specifically
that seems to be
causing that problem.
And I can go through-- active
connections don't seem to be--
they seem to be spiking a bit.
And, again, if there's a query
specifically related to that,
it's easy-- we make it
really easy to find.
So those are a
couple of dashboards
for if you have a single
mission critical database
or something that you want
to really focus in on.
But what about if you have
just a very large number
of databases.
So if you have several dozen
that you're trying to manage,
maybe they're all the same type.
Maybe there's a variety.
And really what you're
looking for are outliers.
So if you want to find something
that maybe is experiencing
issues inside of a, say, in
this case of SQL Server farm.
And this is really
easy to do as well.
So what we have in
this dashboard is
we're monitoring
three dozen databases.
And we have some of
the key performance
indicators for all of those.
So we can identify when one
of them is outside of the norm
whether it's things
like disk wait time--
can see the cache ratio, the
CPU usage, queries instant lock
wait time.
And so a couple of things
I'll see right away,
number 1 is that we see
some of these spikes
that we may want to
investigate but also CPU usage.
This is an unusual one
that's very low on CPU,
so maybe I'll take
a look at this
and try and understand
what's going on with this.
It's outside of the
norm, so there's prod 5.
And we can use the normal
filtering functionality inside
of Stackdriver.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES: And
if the Wi-Fi comes through
for us--
MICHEAL KELLY: But-- let me
give it one more shot here.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
There we go.
MICHEAL KELLY: There you go.
So now I've narrowed it down
to that specific database.
And we can take a look
at what's going on
and maybe get a
better sense of why
this one is so low,
whether it's still needed
or maybe it's something
that we can push off
to another database.
So those are a couple
of the specific ways
that you can use this in
Stackdriver, monitor databases.
Now before I go back,
I wanted to give
a quick overview of our
new logs feature as well.
So if we flip over
to logs, number 1,
I'll mention this is in
alpha, so if it's something
that you're interested in,
please talk with one of us.
We'd love to give you access.
But it won't be
available out of the box.
And this is very similar to
what we're doing with metrics.
But since it's a log--
since it's logs focused,
it's going to run a
little differently.
You do require-- it
does require an agent
on every database or
every workload or server
that you're trying to monitor.
But what we've done
is we've really
tried to simplify the way that
this gets deployed, the way it
handles collecting the logs, and
then how it can be used inside
of Stackdriver.
So you can see I have an agent.
I have it pre-configured
with a destination,
so it's going to send
logs to Stackdriver
to a specific
project I've set up.
I have it configured
for Oracle here.
What if I look at
the sources, there
are a lot of other sources
that are available.
And this is pretty early.
There are a number
here, but we're
adding to them very rapidly.
So you see a lot of focus
on databases to start,
and then that'll expand out.
But if there's something
that you don't see here yet,
we also have generic
plugins that you can use
to gather data and gather logs.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
One really nice feature
of both the monitoring
collector and this logging
agent is lifecycle management.
If you've ever tried to manage
a number of different components
and keep them up to date, you
know how challenging that is.
And this just does that for you.
MICHEAL KELLY: Yeah,
that's one of the things
that we've tried to focus
on as much as possible
because we really believe
that there's been a--
folks have neglected
that side of monitoring.
It tends to be really hard
to get things installed.
They're harder than
I think it needs
to be to get things installed
and then keep them up to date
since things change so rapidly.
So, for example, we're building
these very, very quickly.
We-- frequently we'll release
several per month or at least
updates per month.
It's not trivial to take
that and move it out
to all of your environments.
So I have one of these
databases set up right now.
Just an Oracle database.
Let's take a look at the logs.
So if I go into the logs
viewer first of all--
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
You probably
want to zoom in a little bit.
MICHEAL KELLY: Thank you.
Too much.
There we go.
So you'll see,
first of all, I just
want to note that we have
everything from the Oracle
audit log and a number of
others so Oracle alert log.
And I wanted to show you
that one of the really
powerful things you can do.
So you'll notice here that I
see I have a sys dba user that
has access or is attempting
to access something
within my database.
And within our
environments, that's
considered a major security
flaw-- major security concern.
If we see a lot of these, then
we may need to take a look.
So what I would do is I'd take
that I can create a metric off
of that specific log line and
get an alert setup whenever
there is an issue-- whenever
I identify that that sys dba
user is in use.
And a couple of ways
that I'll come up
is you'll see we have a
dashboard here specifically
for Oracle where we're
combining those logging metrics
that we've created and
the traditional metrics
that you're getting
from our original source
into one dashboard.
And this is useful
because we can see--
this gives me some insight
into things like the security.
I can see how many
of these sys dba--
how much sys dba
activity there is.
I can also see if there
are any failing tasks.
This is something that you
can't get with just metrics
but you can when you
extend it out to logs.
And then right alongside
that I have what
you would expect to see
traditional metrics monitoring
Oracle session count,
session utilization, even
CPU, and query information.
And again we have alerts,
so if you have that alert,
we can set it up.
We can provide good
guidance to the user
on what the actual issue is,
how to resolve that issue, even
reference documentation.
And whenever you get that,
you can automatically
jump into logs and take
a look at the context
around that specific failure.
So let's take a
look and see, well,
now I know exactly where
that occurred, and I
can see the context what
occurred before and after.
So before I wrap up,
just wanted to show you
where you find this.
So we're currently
in the marketplace.
If you just search for
BindPlane or Blue Medora,
it'll come up with our
marketplace listing.
And I'm already activated, but
it gives you a quick overview.
And then you just
click a button,
it'll take you
over to BindPlane.
You'll create an account
for your company,
and then you're ready to go.
We're happy to jump
on a call if it's
something that you
want assistance
with getting started,
but like I said this is--
or like Marie said, this
is at no cost in addition
to what you're already paying
for Stackdriver in GCP.
So with that, I will hand
it back over to you, Marie.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES: So
we've just done a slick demo
showing you all
the cool things you
can do with our new solution
that we're offering to you.
But now I want to talk to an
actual user, real human not
fake, who is using this
today and get his insights
on what it's allowed him to do
and really what it's enabled.
I have to turn off this mic.
So please welcome to the stage
Tim Wright of Eastbound Tech.
Thank you for joining us, Tim.
Why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself.
TIMOTHY WRIGHT:
So that's my name.
That's what I do.
I'm a longtime user of Google
Cloud, specifically Windows.
Been using it since they
released it but have only
used Stackdriver
reluctantly because it was--
my environments were
so mixed with being
on prem and in the cloud.
And so that's a little
bit about where I'm at.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And tell us
about the databases that
they you're working with.
What sort of things are
you're trying to do with them?
What challenges have you faced?
TIMOTHY WRIGHT: So
the biggest challenge
has been, again, the on
prem versus cloud where
I've been running a lot
of Microsoft SQL on prem,
some of it in the cloud
on Windows servers,
and then running
Google Cloud SQL
and then over on some
other platforms run
in some other databases.
And so it's been a very mixed--
definitely a mixed
environment with a lot
of different databases, and
it's been extremely difficult
having, like you said,
a single pane of glass
to look at all the stuff.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And so you've
been using the Blue Medora
Stackdriver solution.
What is that allowed you to do?
TIMOTHY WRIGHT: So it let
me not renew my five figure
solution for SIEM last year.
It let me dump multiple
open source solutions
and actually concentrate
in one place, which
would be Stackdriver.
I use Chef to manage my
BindPlane installations.
It's extremely easy.
I would say I've spent--
we were talking about this
with these guys the other day--
I spent almost no time
in your guys' website,
not because I don't like
it but because it works.
It's simple.
I'm in there.
I can figure my sources
collectors, and I'm out.
And then I'm the rest of
the time in Stackdriver.
So this has really
given me a solution
where I can put a
little bit of effort
and have a huge return compared
to what it costs me to maintain
my installations on the open
source solutions and the paid
solutions.
It's really, really simplified
my monitoring of databases,
not only that but of
infrastructure as a whole.
So I'm dumping all
of my VMware stats
in there, all of that info,
everything from Windows.
It's been huge for me to
have a single pane of glass.
And it's not been
something that--
some of the other
solutions, you had
a lot of promise upfront
of it'll be great.
It'll be like this.
And this has truly been working
with the guys from BindPlane.
It's been fantastic.
I've asked, hey, we should do
this, or this would help me.
And they're like,
all right, sweet.
And then it's out the next week.
Not that they'll do that
every time but they've
been extremely fast,
extremely responsive.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
That's great and thank you
for the strong endorsement.
So it sounds like you're
saving a lot of time
with this solution,
a lot of energy.
What's next for you with all
of that free time you've got?
TIMOTHY WRIGHT: Seriously
mountain biking.
What-- it's allowing me to
give more meaningful data.
And so our-- specifically on
the SQL side, our monitoring
and alerting has been
all over the place
for multiple companies.
And what this is doing is
it's letting me actually
consolidate and simplify.
So it really is time saving.
It takes time to build out
dashboards, build out alerts,
but so far it's been
massively useful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]